there he is present Joseph R Biden the
46th president of the United States
making his way down the steps to be
greeted from behind that presidential
limo with prime minister Rishi sunak a
salute a warm welcome from the Lord
Lieutenant for County Antrim the king's
representative in that part of Northern
Ireland and all smiles from the Prime
Minister very
looking at to welcome the Prime Minister
and as Senator Joe Kennedy there I think
is the new Northern Ireland
representative from the U.S government
who is here on this visit playing a cure
he's going to be staying on I understand
once President Biden does go back to try
and ensure that the U.S government role
in trying to get consensus back and get
power sharing back at Stormont uh keeps
having that sort of impetus yes at the
White House says over the years had many
envoys to Northern Ireland including
Senator George Mitchell himself who
spent four years here brokering the
historic compromise between the
political parties but isn't it
interesting to see Joe Kennedy appointed
as a a an Envoy to Northern Ireland
these days in many ways we've come full
circle right because indeed because it
was President John F Kennedy you could
describe as the most Irish American of
all presidents the Kennedys emigrated
from Wexford in the West on the east
coast of Ireland and made it from
Wexford to the White House in the space
of one generation it's not a bad Journey
well as you as you said David all all
smiles now is the the president is
finally here who said the fourth
president to to come to this part of the
United Kingdom a quick chat there with
uh Rishi sunak and as you say David he's
got a packed schedule ahead of him so
once he's done that's all of the meet
and greet and said the right things and
all the pleasantries will be whisked off
into the city where I guess the work
will begin all preparing for that speech
and and you say it's going to be a
speech to students to some 400 people
I'm told it's going to be about 25
minutes long I mean what do you expect
at the tone of it to be
talk to the Next Generation in North in
Ireland that perhaps suggests that he
isn't so confident that the political
leaders of today are going to manage to
restore the power steering government
and to see the hopes of the Good Friday
agreement become a reality and therefore
he is going to come here and send that
message to a wider audience that it's
time to embrace the hopes of Northern
Ireland um in the hopes that were
established way back on the 10th of
April 1998 on that day when Senator
George Mitchell uttered those famous 19
words I'm pleased to announce that the
two governments and the political
parties of Northern Ireland have reached
agreement it was really a a very
momentous day in Northern Ireland coming
just four years after the terrorist
organizations had declared ceasefires
and it was a it was really a master
stroke in terms of creative ambiguity
because it allowed both unionists and
nationalists to claim that they had
achieved something unionists achieved
the principle of consent that Northern
Ireland will remain part of the United
Kingdom until a majority here vote
otherwise of course we saw prisoners
released early from prisoners part of
the Good Friday agreement and all of the
terrorist organizations pledged to
destroy their weapons so you really
couldn't exaggerate the significance of
that day yeah it was incredible and
being able to give people on both sides
exactly what they wanted so we continue
to look at these pictures it does show
me that this is a family affair we can
see Dr Joe Biden there in the foreground
and off to the right of screen there
that looks to me like Hunter Biden the
president's son there I know that the
bidens did travel to Ireland back in
2017 to check out their ancestry in the
genealogy and just to confirm
whereabouts in the Republic they are
from and of course as we said later on
this week they're going to be making a
similar journey to County louth and
County Mayo there's no no doubt
whatsoever that the president is very
proud of his Irish ancestry having
visited as vice president both those
ancestral counties of live and mayo and
you will remember during his election
campaign just how often he quoted The
Poetry of Sheamus Heaney so I think the
president really has a sense of
connection with Irish culture with Irish
heritage and and how many times do we
hear him saying I'm Irish at one stage
we had that significant moment where
someone stepped forward to doorstep him
as we say in the media and they said I'm
from the BBC and he said I'm Irish so he
didn't want to talk to the British
Broadcasting Corporation that's how
Irish Dubai considers himself and if
you'd be able to say that sort of thing
now but well look we can see that the
delegations are getting into dilemma
into the Beast they're going to be
driving away from Belfast International
having
done the handshakes said their hellos
you know they've just come across the
Atlantic they must be tied and there is
plenty of work ahead for this U.S
delegation here in in Ireland not at
least in Northern Ireland but also once
they get to the Republic to try and
continue to build on that
um 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement and one thought I just want to
get from you David is is this sense of
of President Biden kind of stepping on
uh what has gone before of course such a
huge moment 25 years ago when that
agreement was made Power sharing was
broken down how how much do you think
Biden feels like it is incumbent on him
as a Democrat and as an Irishman to try
and help this thing along a little bit
well America has always been incredibly
staunchly defensive of the Good Friday
agreement not least because they
consider that perhaps President Bill
Clinton's finest moment in terms of
foreign policy achievement and of course
this is another Democratic president in
office now considering a run for a
second term so he wants to demonstrate
that same level of commitment not just
in Ireland but in the Northern Ireland
peace process and that every every time
we've seen a president here it seems to
be at a significant moment Bill Clinton
came because the terrorist ceasefires
had been declared he visited on a number
of occasions not least soon after the
bombing of oma in 1998 this the largest
single atrocity so now we have another
president setting fit on Northern Irish
soil at a time when there is a political
difficulty which has been caused of
course by the consequences of brexit
yeah and which thing the reaction is
going to be from the leaders of those
parties when he meets them tomorrow very
set on either side of this and unwilling
to to compromise I mean voting against
the agreement the dup did in the Commons
just recently
the president comes across the Atlantic
to talk to them what kind of reception
do you think he's going to get well you
heard in my report earlier this this or
the sinfian deputy leader Michelle
O'Neill who's the first nationalist to
have been elected to the office of first
Minister designate says this is always
significant because of what she
describes as America's skin in the game
because America has invested so much in
Northern Ireland and she says it's
really important for him to come here to
express this level of support
politically and economically and uh
there we have the Prime Minister also
just about to depart Belfast
International Airport and make his way
to his own hotel overnight where he'll
be doing some preparation for that
important meeting with the U.S president
in the morning Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris as well
who has also got word today I mean it
just sort of reinforces doesn't it you
know power sharing has been broken down
for a couple of years now is
doesn't seem like it's getting closer to
coming back so these top level
politicians will really want to see if
they can drive it forward a bit and I
guess there's a there was a lot of that
in 197 with a good Friday agreement you
had a new government come in you had a
lot of exhaustion from all those years
of violence that can happen in politics
kind of you can suddenly get like a
little bit of input a little bit of oof
they give something a push come on like
I'm impressed your eyesight's better
than mine being able to pick out Chris
Heaton Harris in the dark at Belfast
International Airport this evening but
he is a man obviously with a lot of work
to do because of the difficulties that's
dormant as Northern Ireland secretary he
has effectively had to step in to govern
this place with a small team around them
for a period of time not that that is a
return to the formalities of direct rule
from Westminster we would have seen
before there was a devolved government
in Northern Ireland but there is a
problem right now we know the problem
exists because the dup were our
boycotting the power sharing government
over brexit and that means Northern
Ireland does not have a functioning
government right now and that's
something we've seen many times the
collapse of the Northern Ireland
assembly the collapse of the power
sharing executive over the last 25 years
the reason for that and I suppose to
some extent it is the flaw in the Good
Friday agreement
mandatory Coalition requires the largest
unionist party and the largest
nationalist party to agree if there is
to be a power sharing government so the
moment they there's a dispute between
them over anything that government
collapses but that political mechanism
which effectively gives a veto to the
largest unionist party and the largest
nationalist party squeezes out the
middle ground their votes don't seem to
be just as valuable and that's why many
people are calling for a restructuring
of the system because the mechanism the
political mechanism that is the Good
Friday agreement to underscore a fragile
piece here are under pen a fragile Pace
here is also the very thing that often
causes the political paralysis very well
David continues to look at these
pictures from Belfast International
Airport you can see tarmac clear the
beasts is rolling President Joe Biden on
his way the short drive 30 40 minutes
from the outskirts of the city into the
city center where it's gonna overnight
before he begins his pack schedule to
Mark the anniversary of the 25th signing
of the Good Friday agreement and also
spend time in the Republic of Ireland it
is ancestral homelands in both County
louth and County Mayo and we'll be
fitting in a good couple of keynote
speeches
there he is President Biden
making his way
into Belfast City Center